une tentation chez toutes celles et ceux
qui ont un jour diriger leur parti et
soutien de françois hollande qui ont
même conduit à la victoire de ne pas
perdre complètement la main et moi je
crois que le meilleur service que
françois hollande puisse rendre
aujourd'hui au socialiste c'est de ne
pas chercher à prendre la main mais de
laisser cette génération qui vient là
prendre complètement et de l'accompagner
plutôt que de la diriger vous lui
demandez aujourd'hui au de cette
émission de d'arrêter les meneurs je
crois que il a compris et je ne veux pas
est ce qui vous fait dire qu'il a
compris j'ai dû relire ici ou là que il
avait décidé de ne pas se mêler être
plus avant du congrès n'avait pas parlé
avec lui laisserait non je n'ai pas
parlé directement inclus vous lui
demandez avait voulu demander d'arrêter
non je moi je ne commande personnes ça
serait mieux mais je le dis je conseille
à tout le monde parce que je pense que
le service qu'on à rendre aux
socialistes et y compris à lui c'est
d'avoir en fait un débat qui soit un
débat d'abord avec les militants un
débat qui donne le sentiment que rien
n'est préemptée